Using this set of chromosomes, we would expect a
female to develop. If we look just at the sex
chromosome pair here, we see that we have two x's.
And two x's means that we don't have a y.
A y is what triggers male development, so in
the absence of the y chromosome, it means that we're
going to get female development. In humans, all females are
genetically xx. They have two x chromosomes. And all males
are genetically xy. They have 1 x and 1
y chromosome. Now, there's no yy combination that exists in
reality. And it's for two main reasons. The first
is that you only have two parents, a male and
a female. So you have someone XX and someone
XY. So there's only one Y to pass down to
the next generation anyways. So, getting a second Y
just really isn't even possible, normally speaking. And the second
reason is that the Y chromosome is a
lot smaller than the X. There's actually a lot
of important information that's on the X chromosome here
that's not on the Y, and without that information,
a human without an X chromosome can't survive.
So you always need at least one X chromosome,
and although there are actually variations on this theme
here. The only two real combinations that we'll talk
about are the XX combination, which develop as
females, and the XY combination, which develop as males.